hi everyone
this is professor m does science and
today i want to talk about angular
momentum
in another one of our videos on rigorous
quantum mechanics
if you have studied classical mechanics
you will know that angular momentum is a
key concept to understand the physics of
many systems so it won't come as a
surprise
that the same is true for quantum
mechanics for example
angular momentum is absolutely essential
to understand the motion of particles in
central potentials an example of which
is the all-important
hydrogen atom but angular momentum in
quantum mechanics is a
lot more general than what you might
suspect from classical physics
you might have heard about this spin of
quantum particles spin
is actually just another type of angular
momentum so what we will do today
is to motivate the concept of angular
momentum in quantum mechanics and we
will also explore how we can
generalize these ideas which will prove
really important as we move forward
so let's go we're going to start with a
reminder of angular momentum
in classical mechanics so let's consider
some reference point
and for ease of visualization let's also
draw
a vertical axis going through that point
precisely
if we have a particle here at position r
that is moving with momentum p and again
for ease of visualization we can imagine
that it is going around the reference
point
in a circle then the angular momentum
vector
l is the cross product between the
position vector
r from that reference point and the
linear momentum p
and this definition is general so you
should view this drawing as simply an
example for clarity
angular momentum like position and
linear momentum is a vector quantity
and this means that for calculations we
typically want to write it in terms of
components defined
with respect to some basis for example
in cartesian coordinates the components
would be
lx ly and lz but moving forward we're
going to be more general
and write these as l1 l2 and l3
we will use the same convention for the
position vector typically given as
xyz but we will label them r1
r2 and r3 and similarly
for the linear momentum vector in this
notation
we can now carry out this cross product
and we find that l1 is equal to
r2 p3 minus r3 p2
and similarly for the other two
components
so what is angular momentum in quantum
mechanics
angular momentum is described by an
observable l hat
which is really made of three
observables
l1 hat l2 hat and l3 hat
in classical physics angular momentum is
a quantity given in terms of position
and momentum
so we can straight away use the usual
quantization rules
to promote these two quantities to the
corresponding quantum mechanical
operators
this means that we can write l1 as equal
to
r2 p3 minus r3 p2
and similarly for l2
and 4l3 and we don't have to worry
about the order of the terms because all
the products that appear
mix position and momentum coordinates
along different
axes so they all commute
now that we have defined the angular
momentum operator in quantum mechanics
the very first thing we need to confirm
is that it is a hermitian operator
so that it is unobservable so let's
start by taking the first component
l1 as an example l1 dagger is equal to
r2
p3 minus r3pt dagger which is equal to
r2 p3 dagger minus r3
p2 dagger now remembering that the at
joint of a product of operators
reverses the order we get p3 dagger
r2 dagger minus p2 dagger r3
dagger the momentum operators
p are hermitian and so are
the position operators are so we get
p3 r2 minus p2
r3 and these two operators commute
because momentum and position appear
along different axes
so we get r2 p3
and similarly these two operators
commute so we get
minus r3 p2 and finally
this equals l1 we could repeat the exact
same derivation for the other two
components and overall
what we find is that each component is
indeed
emission so in conclusion the angular
momentum components
are observables
let's now look at the commutation
relations between the different angular
momentum
components and this is going to be a
little bit long but really interesting
so bear with me
let's start with the commutator between
l1 and l2
using the definition of l1 we get this
and then using l2 we get this
and we can expand out the commutator and
we obtain
these four terms
feel free to pause here for a second to
cross-check this but it
should be clear after a moment
the next thing to do is to remember that
the position operators
commute the momentum
operators also commute and
the position and momentum operators obey
the canonical commutation relations
what these operators tell us is that the
only non-zero commutators
are those that involve mixed position
and momentum operators
along the same axis using these results
we can see straight away that these two
terms vanish
because they only involve position and
momentum operators
along different axes another useful
result to remember now
is that the commutator of a with a
product of
two operators bc is equal to b
times the commutator of a with c plus
the commutator
of a with b times c using this result
we can expand the two surviving terms to
get these four new terms
again feel free to pause the video here
for a moment to double check this step
moving forward the commutators in the
first and last term vanish
because they don't involve the
commutator mixing position and momentum
along the same axis expanding once more
the
two surviving terms we get again
four new terms and again you should
pause if you want
to cross check this step that is
absolutely fine you should really
convince yourself that this
is indeed the result that we get
moving on the two middle terms vanish
the first term contains the canonical
commutation relation in reverse order
so we get minus i h bar and the last
term contains the canonical commutation
relation
so we just get i h bar
let's make some room in this slide and
copy the latest result up here so we can
continue with our derivation
right we can now rearrange it to ih bar
multiplying r1 p2 minus r2 p1
comparing with the definition of l3 up
here
we see that this is in fact equal to ih
bar
l3 we could repeat the same exercise
for the other commutators and we would
find that there are only
two more commutators that are
non-vanishing the commutator between
l2 and l3 which is ihbar
l1 and the commutator between l3 and l1
which is ihbar l2
we can write these relations in a more
compact form as the commutator of
li with lj giving i h bar
sum over k of epsilon i j
k l k in this expression
epsilon i j k is called the levitivita
symbol sometimes also called the
anti-symmetric symbol
and it is defined as follows when the
sub indices are all different
and they appear in the order one two
three or any cyclic permutation
then it is equal to one if all sub
indices
are different but they appear in a cycle
that does
not have the order one two three or a
cyclic permutation
then it is equal to minus one and all
others vanish
if you have encountered the levi tribita
symbol before fantastic
if not don't worry it is simply a
convenient way to write our expressions
in a more compact form but you should
convince yourself that this compact form
is equivalent to these relations up here
a further simplification of the notation
is typically used where we write
this expression without explicitly
including the summation
symbol sigma this is something called
einstein notation and in this notation
we understand
that repeated sub-indices are summed
over
in this example the sub-index k appears
in the levitivita symbol
and in the angular momentum component so
this means we have a sum
over k again if you encountered einstein
notation before
that's awesome otherwise all you need to
remember
is that in this shorthand repeated
indices
are summed over overall the first time
we learn about angular momentum it may
appear tricky to remember all of these
computational relations with all of
these different indices
but in reality it is not so complicated
and with a little practice it will
become
effortless an easy way to remember the
commutation relations for angular
momentum components
is by noting that they obey a cycle one
two three
in the first one up here we have one
here two here
and three here in the second one we
start with two
then three then one and in the third we
start with three
then one then two so they always appear
in the same sequence
the properties of unobservable in
quantum mechanics are determined by its
commutation relations
and in the case of angular momentum the
commutation relations are the ones
up here where as a reminder i am using
the einstein convention
so this should be interpreted as having
a sum over the repeated index
k if we forget about the physical
meaning of angular momentum for a second
then commutation relations such as these
are simply mathematical relations that
we can work with in an
abstract manner in this context we will
find
that in quantum mechanics there is an
observable called
spin that obeys the exact same
computational relations
as those obeyed by angular momentum but
which crucially has no
classical counterpart but because spin
obeys the same computational relations
as the usual angular momentum it can be
understood in very similar terms
so we also call it an angular momentum
in this language we define a general
angular momentum
in quantum mechanics as any observable j
that is made up of three observables j1
j2 and j3
that satisfy these commutation relations
all the properties of the angular
momentum j that are consequence of this
set of communication relations
will be true for any physical quantity
that obeys them
this will obviously include the usual
angular momentum that we have been
discussing
which we will sometimes refer to as the
orbital angular momentum
when we want to emphasize that we are
only discussing orbital angular momentum
we will typically label angular momentum
with the letter
l as we've been doing so far
and similarly for the corresponding
computation relations
but we also have this new type of
angular momentum
that only exists in quantum mechanics
that we call
the spin angular momentum when we want
to emphasize that we're discussing
spin angular momentum we will typically
label
angular momentum with the letter s
similarly for the communication
relations
so you will see angular momentum labeled
by all of l
s or j l and s are used when we want to
clarify
orbital versus spin angular momenta
while j
simply refers to a general angular
momentum which could be
either or a combination of both orbital
and spin angular momenta
as an example of using the general
angular momentum j
and understanding the consequences of
the defining computation relations
let's consider the angular momentum
magnitude
as j is a vector operator with three
components
we can define a magnitude for it as j
squared
which is j dot j in terms of components
this becomes j 1 squared plus j 2
squared
plus j 3 squared this operator is
trivially her mission
because each component ji is hermitian
and in turn this means that j squared is
an observable and we will see in other
videos that it plays a
major role in the quantum theory of
angular momentum
but today let's simply calculate its
commutative with j1
we get these three commutators by using
the definition of j squared
the first one trivially vanishes because
j1 commutes with itself
and for the other two we can expand it
in the usual way
to obtain these four terms
using the defining commutation relations
for angular momentum
these two commutators are equal to minus
ih bar j3 and these two commutators
are i h bar j two
we can see that this term cancels with
this term
and there's one with this one so that
the commutator vanishes
we can repeat the same exercise for the
other components
and they will vanish
and that's it we're done we have defined
angular momentum in quantum mechanics as
any set of three observables that obey
these commutation relations
the fact that the components of the
angular momentum operator in quantum
mechanics don't commute
is a rather remarkable result you will
remember from the video on compatible
observables
that if two observables o1 and o2 don't
commute
then we cannot find a common set of
eigenstates
you will probably also remember from the
video some measurements that if two
observables don't commute
then when we measure one of them we
modify the probability of
finding a given outcome when we measure
the other
we sometimes describe this feature as
saying that we cannot measure
two non-commuting observables
simultaneously
and you will also remember from the
video on the heisenberg uncertainty
principle
that if two observables don't commute
then they are subject
to an uncertainty principle as an
example
remember the videos on the position and
momentum operators which don't commute
with each other
and this means that quantum systems
behave in dramatically different ways
compared to classical systems
for example representing a quantum state
in the position of momentum
representations
in terms of the corresponding wave
functions if we have a very narrow wave
function in the position representation
then this means that we have a very wide
wave function in the momentum
representation
and the opposite also happens and in
general they are related by a fourier
transform
with angular momentum we are taking this
quantum weirdness
one step further it is in two different
quantities like position and momentum
that don't commute
but instead it is the different
components of the same quantity
angular momentum that don't commute
this makes the theory of angular
momentum in quantum mechanics extremely
rich
intriguingly we have found if you
remember in the previous slide
that j squared does commute with each of
the angular momentum components
you should remember this result because
it'll prove useful as we learn more
about the topic
and we'll just leave it here for now
angular momentum in quantum mechanics is
not restricted to orbital angular
momentum
instead we can define a general angular
momentum
j that includes the orbital angular
momentum
but it can also include other types of
physics
so check out our other videos to find
out more about original angular momentum
spin and mixed angular momentum and as
always
if you liked the video please subscribe